[Applaudissements]
les chéris on passe tout de suite à
l'histoire du jour c'est une histoire
complètement dingue à laquelle on va
s'intéresser ce soir à c'est dans un
village situé en Bourgogne un voisinage
entier VI un véritable cauchemar depuis
que de nouveaux locataires ont eménagé
dans le quartier leur logement est
tellement sale et mal entretenu que tous
les voisins sont envoyés par des cafard
des mouches des blates sans parler des
acteurs de dction canine certains ont
été contraints de quitter leur logement
regardez cet extrait du JT de France 3
c'est un truc de fou et Cécile et Céline
voisine du logement à salu seront avec
nous dans un instant regarde
des cafares par centaines une invasion
de mouche voici à quoi ressemble le
quotidien des habitants de cet impasse
la cause présumé de cette insalubrité un
amoncellement de poubelle un couple de
locataire sous tutelle qui a apparemment
pour habitude d'accumuler les déchets
pendant plusieurs jours sans les jeter
il y a quelques semaines une des
voisines de l'impasse a déménagé
incapable de supporter de telles
conditions de vie alors merci Céline
merci
Cécile c'est Cécile Cécile Céline c'est
ça merci d'être là merci d'être là parce
que c'est un cauchemar que vous vivez
qu'est-ce qui se passe chez vous il
paraît que voilà vous avez des voisins
qui sont arrivés quand il y a 2 ans tout
à fait oui il y a 2 ans il y a 2 ans et
qu'est-ce qui se passe c'est c'est c'est
d'une c'est il y a plein de de voilà on
voit les les images les photos parlent
d'elles-même ouais mais comment ça se
fait parce qu'il y a personne qui vient
prendre dans les les poubelles les trucs
c'est une impasse les poubelles sont
dans la rue au-dessus d'accord en
remontant là on peut le voir sur les
photos et ils les sortent pas donc c'est
comme ça comme ils vivent avec leurs
déchets chez eux chez eux oui parce que
là les déchets ont été sortis ils ont
traité l'intérieur la mairie a fait
traiter des excusez-moi
il y a pas de problème il y a eu des
traitements et donc là ils ont sorti
leur matériel interne intérieur à la
maison quand ils ont traité ils ont tout
rentré et donc vous vous habitez à côté
toutes les deux oui ouais moi Mo j'abite
dans la rue d'en face en fait et on est
infesté de de cafar de
blat bah il y a un pe tout quoi il c'est
un vrai bonheur quoi et du coup ben on
est un peu tout seul face à notre
désaris parce qu'on a quand même acheté
nous on est propriétaire toutes les deux
donc on a chacune acheter notre maison
dans fa économie et là ça ça part voilà
on a Chun notre petite
maison bien sûr et on paye des impôts
quand même donc et puis bah là voilà on
est un peu démuni ça c'est une photo
d'il y a 3 jours ouais le cave il paraît
que vous avez arrêté de payer pour les
poubelles pour attirer l'attention de la
mairie ouais c'est moi mais moi moi
bizarrement on m'a retrouvé tout de
suite et on m'a fait une saisie sur
salaire quoi c'est pas vrai ah ouais bah
oui direct ouais vous avez pas le droit
mais ouais moi j'ai pas le loit c'est
toujours comme ça ouais c'est c'est pour
ça que c'est non mais c'est ça qui est
fou c'est toujours comme ça c'est ça qui
est un petit peu agaçant quand même
c'est ça c'està-dire que quand on il y
en a le droit il y en a qui ont le droit
de sortir du cadre il se passe rien
pendant des mois et des mois et vous
vous sortez une fois du cadre vous
rattrapé tout de suite c'est c'est c'est
c'est c'est c'est fou euh vous Cécile
euh vous avez essayé de tout débarrasser
de vous débarrasser des cafards des
bombes à aurosol vaporisateur ça vous a
coûté beaucoup d'argent pour et ça a pas
marché ça ne marche pas parce que ça
revient tout le temps en fait ça revient
tout le temps dès qu'ils vont traiter
chez les voisins donc chez ces
personnesl ouais ça fuit leur habitat et
ça vient se loger chez nous et et en
fait là la photo que vous voyez là en
fait c'est moi quand j'ouvre mes quand
je sors de chez moi j'ai ça devant moi
c'est le premier truc que je vois c'est
ça et la maison que vous voyez là elle
est à l'abandon et elle est en train de
s'écrouler en fait ah d'accord en plus
donc bon là on est sauvé parce
que là on est sauvé parce qu'ils ont mis
des petits grillages voyez donc étant
donné que la maison est extrêmement
grande je pense que ça ça va la retenir
en plus le c'est c'est un et cette
maison elle est infestée de cafar ah
ouais en plus et elle est abandonné on
comprends pas pourquoi la mar mine fait
rien ou les les autorités récemment vous
avez dû quitter votre logement vous oui
pourquoi ben parce que ça devenait
invivable de vivre c'était quoi le
quotidien c'était quoi des cafardes
partout c'est quoi la journée non mais
la nuit oui donc c'est quoi la nuit il
se passa
quoi vous avez les cafares qui rent
partout dans la maison ça partout ver et
donc vous pouviez plus vivre comme ça ah
non là j'endormais avec la lumière là
j'ai rien je suis retourné chez moi
depuis 10 jours et aujourd'hui oui je je
dors avec les lumières allumées je suis
pas sereine para que vous êtes en
dépression à C de cette histoire oui
vraiment c'est un cauchemar c'est un
cauchemar c'est un cauchemar et
malheureusement personne nous entend
vous êtes même suivi par un psychologue
oui à cause de ça h ça a gâché votre vie
ça gâche ma vie encore aujourd'hui donc
c'est je mange plus chez moi je dors
plus chez moi
depuis début juillet et j'ai été hébergé
à tro nuits parci TR nuit par mes
enfants mes sœurs ça votre fils votre
fille votre sœur oui et là vous habitez
où là je suis rentrée un petit peu chez
moi mais ça repart de plus belle avec
les cafars donc je sais pas je sais pas
si je vais rester qu'est-ce qu'on vous a
donné comme solution vous avez dû faire
des démarches la solution de traiter
chez nous c'est un noau frais et c'est
notre problème vous avez été voir les
les voisins ça oui les voisins se
plaignent comme nous d'accord et parce
qu'il y a des voisins qui sont encore
plus parce que bon on est là tout le
monde a pas pu venir on est là pour les
représenter donc il y a des voisines qui
sont encore plus proches puisquils
partagent la même cour commune donc
c'est vraiment et c'éit à un tel point
que le facteur voulait plus passer parce
que en fait dans les boîtes aux letettes
là que vous voyez sur la photo bah
c'était rempli de de blat de cafar et
tout donc même le facteur il voulait
même plus passer c'est quoi fille ce qui
se passe c'est que bon la famille est
sous tutelle le mari s curatel donc la
première chose c'est que je crois que le
dialogue est impossible avec eux vous
avez essayé ils sont même parfois très
hostile et que la mairie est impuissante
et que il y a une réunion demain mais la
mairie ne peut rien faire parce qu'entre
guillemets Cyril cette famille est
protégée donc du coup les affaires
sociales n'agissent pas il faudrait le
retrouver un autre logement il y en a
pas à valallon en ce moment donc pour le
moment c'est complètement coincé et en
plus de ça ils ont le syndrome de Noé
c'est-à-dire qu' ils adoptent tous les
animaux qui Trent il y a des animaux
enfermés dans des cages qui ont la PE
sur les eos qui sont en plein soleil des
fois me moi je comprends pas pourquoi
personne ne fait rien parceil son' sous
tutel curatelle donc du coup ça ne Bou
non mais j moi je veux bien cette
explication mais les détrituses qui sont
à l'extérieur pourquoi elles sont pas r
non ils sont dans la maison ils sont
dans le cadre de la maison ils vivent
dans les détr d'accord mais c'est c'est
de la responsabilité de l'Amérique
d'aller chercher Laue c'est quelque
chose qui est possible ici c'est toutes
les semaines selon les quartiers fait
pas comme ils mettent aussi dans la
maison abandonnée là qui est attenante à
leur enfin elle est pas abandonnée il y
a un propriétaire puisqu'elle est en
vente mais elle est en train de
s'écrouler l'intérieur déjà tout c'est
incrouleré et en fait leur cave de de la
maison qui est en train de s'écrouler
celle-là là on la voit vous voyez la la
cave là il y a une petite porte verte et
en fait ils mettent toutes leur détritu
là-dedans et en fait les cafards bah ils
sont heureux là-dedans puis donc la
mairie elle peut non plus rien faire
parce que c'est privé et ils disent
qu'ils arrivent pas à retouver le
propriétaire le fait qu' a des animaux
pareil là on devrait on pourrait leur
enlever puis pour maltraitance par
exemple on a fait venir il y a déjà eu
des action il y en a déjà qui ont été
enlevés des parce qu'on a une
association trois petits chats à vallon
qui s'est beaucoup mobilisé sur ce sujet
mais encore une fois quoi c'est on a
l'impression que on peut rien faire donc
g verd alors vous Gilles verd tiens TI
env d'avoir là tiens j'ai envie d'avoir
la vie de Gill verdz maintenant là tu
vois là je veux pas d'info je veux de la
vie à 20h50 en direct vous vous faites
quoi là dans 5A comme ça moi je vais
moi-même débarrasser les tous les jours
tu rentres dans la maison et tu vas
débarrasser franchement là oui ah ouais
oui parce que y a pas que Mo c'est
possible ce que vous avez essayé de le
faire parce que je pense qu'il dit
encore n'importe quoimoi je vous aime
beaucoup non c'est ce que je ferais non
tu peux pas dans c'est un domicile privé
privé non mais là tu dis un truc qui est
pas possible fa êre
condamné sinon là je fais le forcing à
la porte du maire je je dors devant la
mairie jusqu'à ce que le maire agisse
voilà et pas l'adjoint qui en ce moment
s'occupe de l'affaire que le maire
d'Avallon agiss on a on a essayé et là
ça commence un petit peu à bouger du
fait que on a fait venir lionne
républicaine on est passé aussi à France
I Bourgogne et Cécile a fait un petit
donc là on commence à être un petit peu
entendu donc j'espère que bon vraiment
ils vont faire le nécessaire mais voilà
parce que en gros on nous dit bah parce
que il faut savoir que c'est quand même
des gens alors c'est pas pour les
incriminés ces personnes qui sont qui
vivent comme comme ça je pense je pense
qu'il y a bien d'autres soucis là-dessus
mais en fait on les déplace de logement
en logement de ville en ville et on
voilà et en fait on déplace le problème
mais on le règle pas quoi on met un
mouchoir dessus et puis B mais ils sont
valides ils son Val alors cette
situation a inévitablement provoqué de
de très grosses altercations lorsque le
voisinage essayie d'entrer en contact
avec ces locataires
regardezys phot as
raison c'est tu à [__] de grosse
vache va pas faire malr va venir parce
que chercher un truc là tu vois voilà
donc là c'est les voisins qui c'est
voilà c'est les responsables de tout ça
donc c'est c'est voilà et donc et donc
il y a eu des altercations forcément oui
avec d'autres voisines c'est avec les
deux voisines qui partagent la cour là
qui bah qui en plus sont le visuel
direct sur les animaux sur tout ça et
bon ça c'est là qu'on marche sur la tête
en faiton dit disait tout à l'heure la
dame elle a pas voulu payer sa taxe
d'ordure elle ilf sais sur salaire parce
que vous êtes solvable parce que vous
avez un salaire eux ils sont valides moi
je pensais que c'est des gens qui sont
pas valides sont très valides ils ont de
l'énergie pour vous insulter en fait le
problème c'est juste qu'ils veulent pas
faire 200 m ou 150 m pour aller dans la
rue déposer les poubelles c'est ça
qu'ils veulent pas faire en fait et donc
on les laisse faire ça parce qu'ils
veulent pas déplacer leur poubelles pour
faire comme tout le monde parce que le
camion de poubelle il rentre pas là donc
faut aller faut aller dans la rue
déposer poub quand même fait venir une
fois une ben exceptionnellement pour eux
pour enlever tout ça mais ils veulent
pas parce que c'est leurs affaires ils
en ont
besoin c'est pas des affaires c'est
c'est c'est un paquet de kebab là c'est
pas des affaires c'est une boîte à kebab
servir l'image que vous voyez le paquet
de kebab là c'est dans la maison qui est
en vente et qui est en train de
s'ébouler en fait voilà donc c'est
encore un autre propriétaire qui la
maison est en vente mais pareil il
trouve pas le propriétaire donc voilà la
maison va s'ébouler en espérant que ça
tue personne et ben merci on va suivre
votre affaire on espère que ça va
s'arranger vraiment pour vous merci
d'être venu et on voulait votre
témoignage ce soir pour que ça bouge ça
peut bougerà et ça va bouger parce sait
que vous vivez des moments difficiles
merci beaucoup on va tout de suite
passer au témoin du jour